yes my friends today is the day that we
build minecraft in react 3
fiber and i would like to mention before
we start
that what you see behind me here is our
starting point
so we already have a player and the
ground
and some sky and so on but if you want
to have a more thorough
explanation from the top about react
and 3 and react 3 fiber there is a video
on barely coding called building 3d
worlds in react
that you could watch before this if you
want to but if you want to keep watching
this one let's jump
right into the code
so this is was actually just a create
react app start and this is the app.js
file
and here you can see what we have so far
we have the sky from dre
we have physics from use canon that is
wrapping the ground and the player
and then we have the positions
coming from this top level so it's easy
to
see how things relate to each other and
so on so we keep
position as a prop that is being passed
in
and for the gravity we have -30 in the
y-axis
we have an ambient light and a spotlight
to get some nice shadows
so let's look in the ground component
the ground has a texture that you saw in
the intro it has a grass texture
it is a repeat wrapping with the same
size
as the actual ground plane we have to
rotate it 90 degrees because if we don't
then it's
vertical we need to lie down and we're
using
use plane the hook from use cannon that
makes this plane
a physical object that can react to
physics
and of course like i mentioned we also
need to wrap the ground in the player
in this physics component also from use
canon
so that's it for the ground for the
player right now all we have
is the camera from the use three hook
we represent the player with a sphere
also from use canon we set it to dynamic
so that it will react to
the gravity and then on every frame
we take the camera that we get from
three
and then we take the position of the
player
this is a ref to this use canon sphere
we copy that position onto the camera
so that the camera will be in the middle
of the player
at all times we also
apart from these two components we have
two hooks one is a use
interval hook we're not using it yet but
i've been planning to use it for
for saving the world every 10 seconds so
that you don't
lose your beautiful minecraft creations
and the second hook is a use store hook
and here we're going to create
the the state of our world using sue
stand
we also have some images for the
different textures of the blocks
i think a good way to start this would
be to create
our state
so we will call our statehook use store
and that will be a call to sue stands
create
and this one takes a callback function
that returns an object
and as an input to this callback
function
we get set from stand
so now we can model our state here
we will need to have cubes that's a
given one
we'll set it to an empty array
we will need to add cubes so we'll have
a function called add cube
we'll also need a remove cube
and apart from cubes we also
since we have multiple textures that
we're going to use on our cubes
we need to store what the active texture
is
so we'll call that texture and default
let's
have good as the default one for now
we need to change the texture so we'll
have a set texture
function i mentioned that we're going to
save our world
and that could be a function on the
state as well
there we go if we have stored the state
of our world
in our local storage then we need
the initial state to become whatever is
stored in the local storage
so i'm going to create two helper
functions here
called get local storage and set local
storage
so the cubes will come from local
storage
if there is an entry in local storage
called world
so we'll say get local storage
world but if we don't have that
we'll just set it to an empty array when
we call
save world we will call set
and inside set we have another callback
function
where we receive the state
so now we have access to the whole state
so here we do
set local storage key was world
and what we want to store is stapled
cubes
so let's think about what each cube will
look like
it will be an array of objects and
each cube
will have two keys one for the position
which will also be an array with x y and
set
and the second one will be the type
for example would so here we would be
like
zero zero zero so let's think about what
do we need
to know about a cube that's being added
well we need to know
where to place it so we need x y instead
and we also need to know
what type it is so here we can also do a
set
we receive the state
and we return a new object
and for the cubes
we need to take all the old cubes
so we sprayed spread state dot cubes
and then we add our new cube which has
position x y and z
and the type
there we go that should add our new cube
to the array of cubes
when we're gonna remove a cube
all we need is xyz we don't care about
the type
we just want to filter out the cube that
is being called
to be removed so we take in
xyz
again we call set
we receive the state
and we return state
dot cubes dot filter
cube and here we need to check
cube dot x not equal to x
for
cube dot y not equal to
y cube dot
said not equal to
said so what this line is doing
is saying that if any of the coordinate
does not match
then keep it but if all of the three
coordinates match
then filter it out so this should allow
us to remove
a cube if we pass in three coordinates
setting of the texture then we just need
to receive the new value of the texture
texture
same thing again we get the state
we just return an object where
texture
like that i think that should be it
for for the state functions
so now we actually added one
cube on the default state
and that's good that we can use that one
uh
to when we when we build our cube
component
to see if this one single cube will be
rendered
in the middle of our world okay now we
have the state out of our way
and we can continue with more fun stuff
visual stuff so let's create
a component that represents one of our
cubes
so cube.js okay and this cube is going
to be
a physical object that we can stand on
so we will use
use box from
use canon
and we want to receive the position
and the type of cube from
the props
and we can take in the rest of the props
in the props variable what we should
return from this function
is a mesh
and we want the cubes to be able to cast
shadow so we'll add this
the cast shadow prop to the mesh
and now let's call use canon
so we get a reference to this box from
use canon
so we call use box and here we pass a
callback function
and it should return
an object so we'll wrap it in
parenthesis
and this object will have type static
because
these boxes in minecraft or cubes in
minecraft they're not
falling around they're just static where
they're placed
we get the position so we'll set the
position in here
and we can spread the rest of the props
in here as well so that if we pass
something into the cube
they're automatically passed into the
use box
and this should be a string
so now we have a reference here we want
to
put this reference on our mesh
so ref is equal to ref
let's add our geometry here a box buffer
geometry
and we attach it as geometry
like that okay now we have a cube that
takes in position and type
and that renders itself out
so now we should be able to place a cube
position
is equal to
we need to import the cube here
i will pass the type
we would but we're not using type yet
so there we go now we actually see
our cube but it is below ground
almost so we'll set the cube position to
be one
and it will come up so our next step is
to
add some texture to this box
so we'll go back to the cube
and i prepare this file that just has
all the textures and where we want to
use all the textures
we can use import star
from
textures and we'll call it
textures now we have all our textures in
this textures variable and we can see
that
all of these exports are now in the same
object
so if we want to access the texture
we do it by these names
and those names should be the same as we
get as the type here
but since we have six sides to this cube
we need to do a little loop here we'll
create an array
array of length 6
and we'll map it we will just use the
index
so i'll do underscore
and then the index so what we return
from this map
for each site is a mesh
standard material and it should have
some props
attach array as material
map is where we send in the actual
texture
so we take from our textures variable
which is an object
and we want to look up the type so this
will for example be wood
and then we would get that texture
okay we can just use use the index for
this key
i think that should be enough let's see
if we have a wooden box
let's see line 15.
oh we need to return this
so we can do a parenthesis instead
no wood yet let's see why
i'm passing in type wood and in textures
we have a texture called
wood attach array map textures type
okay i had to instantiate this
array with this with a spread
and then it worked okay so now we have
a nice cube here we have the rice
texture so we can see that we do in fact
have a shadow
but right now we can't
even move towards it or look around it
or anything because we still can't move
we just represented by a sphere and we
drop
on top of the ground so
we should figure out how to look around
and to move around
using the wasd keys
i would like to create a hook that the
player can call
where they would get an input of where
to move
essentially is the keyboard telling us
to move forward backward jump and so on
so let's create a hook called
use keyboard controls
use keyboard
controls dot js to start out with
let's first make a mapping between the
key code
and the action and the action will just
be described by
as a string for example
we make a function called action
by key so you pass in the key
and you get back the action
that that key triggers so we can do an
object in here called keys
so for example key w which is how you
move forward in
first person shooters
move forward so this we can call
anything this is just
for us to understand what each key is
doing
so we'll just type this out real quick
there we go
we have forward back left right and then
jump
with space let's create the same thing
but for for the different textures
and i will put those on the digits one
to five
function texture by
key there we go so i put dirt on one
then grass glass wood and
five gets the log
so it's the same as the actions
basically
now let's create our actual hook use
keyboard controls export post
so inside this hook we will need some
state
to keep track of things let's import
use state from react
so we'll create a piece of state called
movement
movement set movement
use state and this piece of state will
be an object
and here we use the very same
wording that we have here
so let's remove all the keys and we'll
set all of these to false
there we go now we have a
movement piece of state here we can use
so for the texture
we don't need to have any internal state
because we can just call the the store
to change
the texture for us
so let's import the store import
use store
from
so here we can just we want that
function that we created called
set texture because that's what we want
to call
if we get a digit between one to five we
just want to change the texture
so use store
and then we can give it a callback
function
that gives us the state
so then we can return what piece of
state that is the function sec
texture so that it's state dot
set texture so now
our set texture function in here will be
the set texture function from
the state actually we don't even need to
have it in
an array we can do it just like that
now we need to import use effect
because now we're doing the the key
event listeners
use effect
so the most important thing is that we
do document
add event listener listen for
key down and then we need a function so
we'll call it handle
key down and we'll have
another one for key up
and since we're adding event listeners
what we should return from our use
effect a function that
cleans this all up
so we'll do the same thing but we
remove okay so now it's time for
us to create the handle key down and
handle key up functions
we get an event so we'll first
check if the key that we press down
is a movement key
action by key e dot
code so if we
come into this if statement that means
that we did click
a movement key then we can call
set movement
we get a call back there where we
receive the state
and we return an object from this
where we spread the previous state and
one of the key codes or one of the keys
has changed and it's now
pressed down so we know that
the action by
k e dot code
that one should be true
so we keep the state as it was but we
know for this value
which will be one of these keys it
should be true
so this will handle all the movement
keys
let's also handle the texture case here
if texture by key
e.cold
then we know that we want to call set
texture
and then we can just go through the find
the name
of the texture represented by that key
so we'll do
text texture by key
e dot code and pass that in and then
we should be good to go so now let's
handle the key up
so this should be very similar to this
one
i mean we don't have to react to a
textured key coming up
we just react to a texture key going
down
so if we have a movement key
we just have to flip this to
false and that should be it
for we also have to return
our state for the movement so we return
movement so what we will get back
is this object every time
and if we click a key these booleans
will
if we press down w a s d
or space these booleans will flip to
true
and we will get the hook will call us
with the new
values so now we can actually use this
hook inside our player
import use
keyboard controls
from hooks
use keyboard controls so now we can
destructure out
these move
forward move backward
move left move right
and jump
equals use keyboard controls
so now we have values that will change
based on
if we click down our keyboard by using
this hook
so let's try that this actually works
if we console log
move forward for example
forward
now we'll go to the browser and i will
bring up the console w
forward true and when i release forward
false
pushing down releasing
so that's great it all seems to work
fine so
what we want to do is when we receive
these inputs we want to move this
sphere so we also get
an api back from the sphere as the
second
return in this array here we can
continue in our
use frame here let's have first a
representation of the
direction and we'll use a
vector for that vector3
since we have x y and z and we can think
of it
as one force going forward
and another force going to the side
so i will call the going forward i will
call it
front
vector
i will represent that with the vector 3
as well
and we'll give it some values so for the
x it will always be zero
because that's that's the sides for the
y
it will always be zero because that's up
and down but
for the said position that is back and
forth
so here we want to look at the move
forward and move
backwards values and
we can think of it like that we take the
the force going forward and subtract the
force going backwards so if we
hold front and back at the same time
they cancel out to zero because
otherwise
weird things could happen so we can do
it like this if we get move forward
we add one to this and then we subtract
one if we're also pressing moving back
so if we have both we get one minus one
otherwise we get one
if we're only pressing move back we get
only minus one
so how would we do that we do move
forward
if that one is true it's one otherwise
zero
and then we take minus
move backwards if that one is true
we take a one otherwise zero it should
be as easy as that
and then we do the same for going to the
sides
but then it's actually this value
the x one that is going to change
so we set this one to move left
and this one to move right
i will change the name to
left or side vector this one should of
course be three
and this one should also be three
okay so now we have three vectors
one for direction one for the front and
back
and one for the sides now we need to do
some
weird calculations on these to figure
out
how to set the velocity of this sphere
so we'll take this empty direction
vector
and will create a vector from
the side vector and the front vector so
we'll do
sub vectors
front vector side vector
so now we combine them
then we do something called normalize
which is
basically you make a vector to have the
length 1
which is a very common thing to do
because now we're going to multiply it
by our speed constant of the player
which we haven't created yet
so we'll do multiply scalar
and we'll call this constant speed
and let's create this constant const
speed and we'll set it to
six and the final thing we need to do
is apply euler
so the the euler is the most i hope you
can see there
the euler is the most complicated one of
this because that is taking
a rotation and a force and seeing
how much that this force affect that
direction based on
the offset in rotation from that
direction that's
as easy as i can put it i think
so we create a vector from the front and
side vector we normalize them we
multiply them and then we see
like where am i looking compared to this
force
so the final step for us apart from the
jumping
is to
actually apply this direction
to our sphere so we'll do api dot
velocity dot set
direction dot x the front and side is
just for the
x and the z axis for the y
we want it to stay the same so the x we
get from direction
y we don't know what to do yet but
for the set we also get it from the
direction
so the y needs to just stay the same
so what we can do is that we can use
a ref use ref we'll create
a ref here called
velocity i'll say use ref and we'll set
it
zero zero zero so we can
we can use this one to keep track
of the y velocity so we can do
velocity dot current
not one because it's the y the middle
one
and we want this reference to the
velocity to
follow the velocity of our sphere so to
get that
working we create a use effect so in
here we do api
that's the sphere dot velocity
and then we subscribe to it
so here we get a call back we get
the velocity passed in so then we can do
velocity which is a ref dot current is
equal to v
so this will keep keep them tied
together
and then the dependency for this use
effect is api
dot velocity we need to import
use effect as well
okay so let's see if it actually works
i'll press w okay w
takes us backwards s also takes us
backwards
a takes us to the left and d also takes
us to the left
so we're probably close to getting it to
work but there is a bug somewhere so
let's see if we can find it
is there maybe in the use keyboard
controls
move left move right we could
console log the whole
uh use keyboard controls just to see
that
we get the correct keys back console log
move forward move
backwards move
left move right
okay let's see if those are correct so
i'll press w
only w became true s only s became true
a was also correct d
was also correct so it's not our hook
that is the error
it's probably one of our calculations
then i wonder if i need to have
parentheses around these ones
let's see front and back works now
okay now they work but they are opposite
so w takes us backwards and s takes us
forward
so that's an easy fix we just have to do
this
and let's add parentheses to these ones
as well
okay let's see yeah now the sides work
so w forward s back a
left and d right cool now we can see the
sides of our box
so the final thing in our controls is
that we get
the first person first-person shooter
controls or the
it's also called pointer lock controls
so
we will look where our pointer goes okay
for the
first person view or the mouse controls
i will create a new component and i will
call it
fpv controls for first person view
controls
and there is actually an example that
we're going to use from
from the three js examples so i will
copy this
example so it looks like this
import pointer lock controls as pointer
lock controls
implementation and what you do is that
you
extend and pass
in an object with pointer lock
controls implementation like this
just following an example here so we
need to import extend
and did it automatically now we can do
export const fpv
controls is equal to
here we get props
so we need a reference to the camera
from use
three
and let's create a ref two
controls so we need to import user f
react use riff
from react and use three from
from reactory fiber we need to have a
use effect because
we're going to start these controls when
we click on the document
use effect
here we do document
dot add event listener and it's a click
and the callback function
here we're gonna call our
controls.current.log
so if we click on the document then we
lock our controls to the camera let's
import use effect
and this only needs to run once so we
put an empty array
as the dependencies and now
we return pointer lock
controls info
and it needs some props we need a
reference to the controls
we need to pass in some args
so we need to pass in the camera
as the first property and the second
should be
the gl dom element so we can get the gl
from use three
and then we can do gl dot dom element
that should be it for this component so
now
we want to render this component inside
the player
fpv controls
from fpv controls
and we'll just render it here fpv
controls
so let's see if we broke our game now
when i click on the screen it should
lock to my mouse
this is so cool
so now i can change rotation and when i
press the w
it will move according to my rotation
so now i can explore the different sides
of the cube that's super awesome i can
look at the sun and so on
so we've come a long way we have a
working movable player
we have a cube component so
now we're going into the more minecrafty
stuff
so one big part of minecraft is adding
cubes to other cubes
so we need to have like a hover state
on a cube so that you can see if you're
actually looking at a specific cube
and also what side of the cube we are
looking at
because what side we're looking at will
determine where we place the
next cube if it's on top or on the sides
so let's go into the cube component and
create
a hover state so first we
import use date
we'll call it hover and
set tower i will
initialize it just to know so now let's
go down to this mesh
and for the hover we need to do on
pointer
move we get an event
and we also want to
stop the event propagation because we
want this to affect
just one of the cubes and not all of the
cubes that are behind the cube that
we're actually looking at so we'll do e
dot stop
propagation here we want to set
our hover
so in this event we get
something called phase index and for
each side of the cube
there is actually two phases because in
these 3d worlds
everything consists of triangular
polygons so each square
side actually has two triangles on it
so to figure out the index of the face
that we want to set we need to divide it
by two
just because there is two per phase of
the cube
so we just we round down so we do
math.floor and we do
e dot phase index divided by 2.
so now we if this was correct we have
set
the correct phase index of the cube that
is being hovered
and since we are mapping the different
faces here
and this index and this face index
lines up we can set
a different color to the the side of the
cube that we're actually looking at
so we'll say color hover is equal to the
index
we set it to gray
otherwise we just set it to white so
if everything works where we look the
this that side of the cube should turn
gray
so i hover here yes it's working
so you see
the side that is being hovered is
turning gray
so that's super cool so now we can and
if we
go into pointer lock control we can
actually
figure out where
where we are looking and where we are to
place the next cube
so that that's a great step forward
the next step for us could be to make
the cube even better
we could hard code in the store
a few more cubes that have some
different
textures so if we go into here
where we hardcoded our wood cube
we could create a few new ones
we have five different textures so we
create
five cubes one more
so it was wood dirt
grass
glass and what was the last one log i
think
i mean we also have to loop from the
store
these cubes instead of just hard coding
it
inside the app component like this so i
added them now
into the store and we also
we need to place them properly i mean we
could do
two for one of them one this one we
could move a little bit to
what to the side and this one as well
i think now they're not in the same
place and they have the different types
so now let's go into our app component
and instead of just hard coding one cube
we will get the cubes from the store and
we will loop them out
so we will import our storehook
const cubes is equal to use
store here we
make a callback function that receives
the state and we just return
state dot cubes so now we should have
our array of cubes
so let's do a loop here cubes.map
cube
so we return
a queue and for the position
we pass in cube.puss
and for the type
we pass in cube dot type
or was it texture
let's see it was texture
texture let's see if i used
type anywhere else type this should be
texture
this should be texture now we've used
texture everywhere
perfect so let's go back
to our loop texture is cube.texture and
position is cube.position
so i think now it could actually work
that we get
these five cubes all with different
textures
looped out
texture is not defined
texture there we go
hmm let's see
yes these ones also need to have one
one there we go now we can see them
all so we have the
this one does not work and
the hover is sticking so
to fix the sticking of the hover color
we need to add
on pointer out
e
we just set hover to null
that should fix it
yes that's great let's figure out
the i think it's the log texture that is
not working
did i call it log i call it i called it
woo
log great now we have the log as well
one thing that i want to fix for the
glass
color it's that this glass should have
transparency so
let's add transparency to the glass
so it should not be so hard to add some
transparency
to the cube if the texture is glass
you just add a opacity prop here
to be texture equals
glass if that one is true
then we set it to 0.7 otherwise we'll
set it to 1.
and for transparency to work we also
need to set the prop
transparent to true
so now let's see if we have some
transparent glass
yes now it's see-through
really cool okay now let's go
into creating or adding new cubes so we
need to import
our use store hook in the cube component
and we want to import add cube
remove cube and the current active
texture from the you store
add cube remove
cube and the active
texture we'll call it since we already
have texture here we call it
active texture
now we get things from the store we
already know
i'll type it out real quick there we go
and
the add cube and remove cube should be
on clicks but i think
we can have remove cube if we hold down
a key and click
and of course the texture just comes
from
the keyboard hook so
this piece of state we only need to
consume in this
so let's add an on click method here
again we want to stop propagation so the
first step is to figure out
what side of the cube was clicked
so click face and we'll do the same
thing as we did for the hover
math.floor e dot face
index divided by two
and we do have a reference to the box
that represents the cube here
so we can get the xyz from that
box by restructuring it
ref dot current dot
position so here we need a bunch of
if statements we can do if
clicked face zero
we call let's
we can do add and remove at the same
time by doing
e dot alt key was it an alt click
or like was the alt key held down when
we did the click
if it was we do remove cube xy said
otherwise we do add cube x
y said and we need to pass in the
texture which is called
active texture the one we got from the
state
so now i just need to duplicate this for
all the six faces
okay so now i added all the faces and
for remove cube we want to remove the
cube that we clicked on
but for add cube we don't want to place
it
in the exact same place we want to place
it
to the side or above or below the cube
corresponding to the
face that we clicked so that's why i
have to do
x plus one x minus one y
plus one y minus one z
plus one and said minus one
so i think we can actually try this out
now
so let's go up to the cube
place one here oh and we do get a wood
cube
so now we can actually try out our
texture switcher
so that i click i press digit two
so now i should have switched to a
different texture
and that was grass press three
and that's the glass four
it's wood again that's right
five log let's press one
dirt so now we can actually place cubes
that's super cool so let's try removing
of cubes i
look at this one i hold down alt and i
click
it does not work is there something
wrong
oh this does not look correct
this should return an object
cubes is equal to the filter cubes
now maybe remove will work a bit better
click
all hold alt and click
no oh i think i know what i'm missing
i need to structure position from the
cube
it should be position here
position position
now maybe still know
ah wait it's not an object it's an
array
now maybe
i forgot to add a return to the clicked
face here that's why sometimes things
were behaving a bit
weirdly now maybe now
yes let's get rid of these initial cubes
now
so we'll start from a clean slate
now let's add the ability to set our
first cube
because then we're not clicking on a
cube to create another cube
then we're clicking on the ground so
we'll add an on click
to this ground mesh
so again we want to do e dot stop
and here we want to get x y and z from
the actual
click so we'll
structure that
and we can do object dot values of the
e dot point
and then we do a transform of those
so for each chord we return
a rounded up
of that chord and then we can do add
cube
x y instead and now of course we need to
import
also the store import
use store from
books use store
but we also need to pass in the cube
we'll call it
active texture
active texture okay
let's try it out let's click the ground
and it works we do get a cube
and we can remove it now let's figure
out
how to use an interval to save
our world every 10 seconds so that we
don't build something cool and
lose it so we need to also get our save
world function here
from the store
state dot save
world
and now we want to import another hook
for the interval function
use interval take the callback function
and how often it should run
as the second argument let's do it every
10 seconds
in here we want to do save
world and pass in the cubes
we can do a console
log saved so now let's see if we place a
cube
we wait for it to say saved saved and
now i
try to reload and it worked
we have one movement that we haven't
finished yet and that is the jump
so let's see if we can jump on top of
this box
so we are back in the player and as we
can see the jump
keyboard control is not yet used in this
file
so let's go to the end of our use frame
hook here so we'll say if jump
and we also need to check if we are
standing on the ground because otherwise
we can jump
over and over again and go higher and
higher so the
math dot absolute value
will take our velocity of
the sphere which is the player
velocity so this is the velocity ref
that we have connected to the sphere
dot current 1 which is the y
velocity in the y direction
2 fixed will round it to 2 decimals
i will check if this one
is smaller than 0.05 that means that we
have
very little speed in the y direction
if we get the jump key
and we're not moving fast up or down
already
we do api dot velocity dot set
and for the x we want to keep our
velocity
so we'll do velocity dot current
zero which for the x
for the y we want to add a bunch of
speed
so we'll add eight and for the
set we'll keep the same so similar to
the x we do velocity
alt current two
okay now we can try out
our jumping so i will press space now
and it works see if we can jump up onto
this cube here
cool and one more thing that we should
add
is to import
nano id so we can set a unique id to
every cube
nano id
from nano i did then we can do
here key is
nano hopefully that should work
yes
let's build something
okay i'm done
so i will link to the code base in the
description and
if you want to start out like i did in
this video there will be a dev branch
that you can use for that i will also
deploy the game somewhere so you can
just
go to url and try it out and if you
enjoyed this video
then give it a thumbs up and consider
becoming a subscriber to the channel
i hope that you learned a lot by
watching it and that you had fun
so until next time take care bye
you